today's protagonist was born as a prince
in a southern Indian Kingdom but he soon
discarded his palace life to embrace the
study of Buddhism as a travelling master
he journeyed to China where he gains
powerful disciples and founded dianna
Buddhism better known in China as Chan
and later in Japan Zen he is also
credited as the first kung-fu master at
the temple of Shaolin he popularized
meditation introduced green tea to China
and had a curious second life as a
popular Japanese doll put the kettle on
the stove control your breathing and
sink into the life and legends of
buddhadharma also known as demo in China
and ARIMA in Japan here is the life and
legacy of the 28th Buddha most of what
we know about Buddha Dharma is painted
in the colors of legend however there is
a historical account of his life written
by the Chinese monk - Wong in the 7th
century AD where did armors exact date
of birth is not known we do know that he
was active throughout the first half of
the 6th century AD and was born in the
South Indian kingdom of pallava
corresponding to the present-day states
of Tamil Nadu Karnataka and Andhra
Telangana at birth he was called Bhatia
Terra and he wasn't exactly just another
citizen of pallava he was a royal prince
the third and youngest son of King sim
harvin the second the capital city of
pallava was a place called kaanchi and
it was a prominent center of buddhist
scholarship giving birth to many Masters
of the Mahayana strand of Buddhism the
king himself was interested in the
Dharma attend which indicates the words
of the Buddha the practice of his
teaching and the attainment of
enlightenment that is why he arranged
for he and his sons to be trained by the
famed master Prajna tarah present era
was the 27th in a lineage of masters and
disciples that could be traced back
directly to siddhartha gautama known
simply as the buddha the famous founder
of the religion during the course of the
training the master
noticed the spiritual potential and
wisdom of the youngest Prince but he
decided to wait before making of Bhatia
tarah his chosen disciple the time was
finally ripe when the King died while
everyone was in mourning botella Terra
remains in a deep state of constant
meditation for seven consecutive days
offer finally rising a full week later
he went to present Hara and requested to
be accepted as his disciple Fresnel
Terra took him under his wing and
imparted all of the necessary teachings
to make of him a new master under the
guidance of his mentor body--it ARA
deepened his understanding of the dharma
but also mastered Ayurvedic medicine
acupuncture and martial arts when he
eventually became Bodhi or awakens
prashna Terra gave him his new name
Bodhidharma
he had now become the 28th in that
unbroken lineage of realized masters I
expected by now your water has boiled
and your greens Hebrews for the three
minutes required for the perfect cup so
let me give you a quick summary of the
main tenets of Buddhism Buddhism is a
religion based on the teachings of
Siddhartha Gautama born in the fifth
century BC in modern-day Nepal he was
known by his title the Buddha meaning
the awakened one after he experienced a
profound realization about the nature of
life death and existence the Buddha
traveled and taught throughout his life
but he didn't teach people what he had
begun to understand when he became
awakens instead he taught people how to
realize this awakening for themselves
which would arrive through their own
direct experience rather than beliefs
and dogmas he wasn't offering an answer
he was teaching his pupils how to ask
the right question by the 3rd century BC
Buddhism had become the state religion
in India and from there it spread
through the rest of Asia today the
number of Buddhists is estimated to be
about 350 million which makes Buddhism
the 4th largest religion in the world
although it is questioned whether it
should be considered a religion at all
Buddhism is non-theistic at its core and
coexists with other established
religions as a result some scholars
choose to consider it more or as a
philosophical doctrine than and explicit
religion nomenclature
detail that sense Buddhism apart from
other religions is the lack of dogmatic
truths to be memorized and believed the
Buddha taught his followers how to
realize truth for yourself so its focus
is on practice rather than belief in
spite of this emphasis on free inquiry
Buddhism does provide some explicit
beliefs known as the Four Noble Truths
the truth of suffering or dukkha the
truth of the cause of suffering samudaya
the truth of the ends of suffering or
gnuhata the truth of the path that frees
us from suffering or Magga practitioners
are encouraged to explore the teachings
that shape these truths and test them
against their own experience about 2,000
years ago food isn't divided into two
major schools
Theravada and maya hana which i
mentioned earlier the second is the
school to which bodhidharma adhered to
the two schools differ in their
understanding of the concept of anarta
buddhists believe that there is no self
in the sense of a permanent integral
autonomous being within an individual
existence the Theravada school considers
anata to mean the an individual's ego or
personality is a delusion once freed of
that delusion the individual can enjoy
the blissful state of Nirvana my
anabolism goes further considering all
conscious phenomena as a void of
intrinsic identity they craft identity
only in relation to other phenomena the
implication is that there is neither
reality nor unreality only relativity
this teaching is called Shunyata or
emptiness another defining aspect of
Mahayana is the Buddha nature this is a
fundamental nature accessible to all
beings which offers the potential to
reach the awakening or enlightenment
through practice according to 13th
century Japanese monk a high dogging
Enlightenment's is intrinsic to the
Buddha nature therefore all beings are
already enlightened but we need to
clarify the nature of our existence to
experience the awakening that was always
there okay so with that out of the way
it's time to sip your tea while I
continue with our story
[Music]
after completing his training
Bodhidharma was instructed by prashna
terra to travel to china and impart the
teachings of mahayana upon arriving but
Adama felt that people were too focused
on the conventions of Buddhism rather
than its essence they were too
preoccupied with building temples and
chanting rather than looking into their
own minds for spiritual growth sometime
after arriving Bodhi Dharma was invited
to a monastery to deliver a lesson to a
large number of students but the master
just sat in front of them meditating
hours passed by with voda Dhamma ever
undisturbed by the whispers and murmurs
of an impatient assembly eventually he
just silently stood up and walked away
that he gone crazy
was there a mystical meaning behind his
silence his simple intent was to shock
them to get the students to consider
abandoning the pursuit of the exterior
trappings of Buddhism to focus on a
journey towards the realization of
Shunyata emptiness through the means of
meditation dianna in Sanskrit or Chan in
Chinese the news of these teaching
methods reached emperor wu of southern
china an avid practitioner of mahayana
buddhism he supported the monastic
orders generously built many temples
promoted vegetarianism and bans the
sacrifice of animals and capital
punishment believing he had earned an
audience with a wise master like Bodhi
Dharma
Wu summons the Indian master to his
court and recounted his own great deeds
he then asked having done all these how
much merit do I have but Adama replied
none the emperor was taken aback by this
answer and pressed on what is the first
principle of the holy teachings
Bodhidharma replied vast emptiness
nothing holy but will did the Emperor
continued who is standing before me then
Bodhidharma replied I don't know this
conversation may have never happens but
it is one of the first recorded Cohen's
paradoxical anecdotes or riddles used in
Zen Buddhism to invite deep
introspection the meaning of this Cohen
is to undermine the idea of identity and
holiness the emperor is portrayed as
performing good deeds but these are just
meant to reinforce his ego to use a
modern concept a king who clings to his
ego will never
the Bliss of Nirvana or the freedom of
liberation for the second question of
the emperor the Masters response points
out that there is nothing to cling to
you as holy everything is inherently
holy trying to differentiate between
holy and unholy is quintessentially
unholy and the third response shatters
again the concept of ego this time for
boded armor himself as his thoughts are
passing through him like water in a
river nothing stays as the true
Bodhidharma self-image is only a mirage
the story goes that we did not fully
comprehend Bodhi Dharma's teachings and
continued on without a true sense of
understanding only later did he realize
the depth of Bodhi Dharma's message and
he lamented alas I saw him without
seeing him I met him without meeting him
I encountered him without encountering
him now as before I regret this deeply
Bodhi Dharma continued his journey to
the city of Nanjing on the Yangtze River
there he came across a large crowd
rallied around a famous Buddhist monk
shangguan who happened to be a former
warrior a general and one who had not
entirely lost his taste for aggression
boat Adamas sat down to listen to
shangguan but his constant nodding
irritated the ex-soldier eventually
shangguan raised his rosary of heavy
beads and hid boated armor in the face
out of frustration the blow knocked out
two of the boded armors teeth but the
master just smiled and walked away
shangguan was intrigued by this reaction
and immediately started following the
indian master when he reached the banks
of the Yangtze River he was startled by
the sight of Bodhi Dharma gently gliding
through the water standing on a single
read as if completely weightless well he
could do that too could have seen seeing
an old lady with a bundle of reeds on
the bank Shangguan snatched two reads
off her tossed them onto the river and
jumped on them naturally he drowned well
he almost did as the old lady who was
kind enough to pull him out of the water
as Cheng wons anger boiled over he
realized that the man he was following
may have been trying to teach him a
lesson
quite literally he had acted out of
aggression and mindlessness without
considering for a second that Bodhi
Dharma may have been able to sail on a
single read by virtue of his mindfulness
shangguan had been dragged down into the
water by the weight of his physical body
as well as the weight of his ownself the
former general had run after bodhidharma
out of curiosity but now all he wanted
was to really know the man he wished to
become his disciple Bodhidharma
continued his journey and around the
year 527 ad he finally reached his
destination the temple of Shaolin one of
the major centres of Buddhism in China
found it by another Indian master
buta pedra in 495 ad the Shaolin monks
had heard of his approach and were
gathered to meet him when they invited
Bodhidharma to come stared the temple
though he did not reply instead he
walked to a nearby cave on a mountain
behind Shaolin sat down and began
meditating hear the stories tell us that
the Indian master sat facing a cave wall
and meditated for nine consecutive years
according to one story his concentration
was so intense that an image of his body
was engraved into the stone of the wall
before him according to another account
as stillness was so unbroken that all
four limbs eventually withered and fell
off other legends claim the Bodhi Dharma
was unable to stay fully awake during
his nine years of meditation out of
frustration he pulled out a knife and
proceeded to cut off his eyelids as the
two scraps of skin fell on the grounds a
tea leaf sprouted on the very spot the
first to ever grow in China but for now
I'm going to stick to an account in
which the Masters body remains intact
inside the cave
in the meantime Shen grant had caught up
with him unable to get a word out of
body Dharma that Chinese monk decided to
stay outside the cave and stand guard
every so often
both shangguan and the Shaolin monks
would try and interact with buddhadharma
but no one ever received a reaction
finally after nine years have passed the
puzzled monks decided that they had to
do something for the enigmatic master so
they built a special room inside the
temple just for him that the Shaolin
monks invited Bodhidharma to come and
stay inside the room so which he did not
immediately respond instead he stood up
walked to the room sat down and
immediately began meditating he did this
for another four years
Shen Wong had been standing garden out
for a total of thirteen Windsor's all
his requests to be taught by Buddha
Dharma had been ignored in a fit of
frustration shangguan
picked up a large block of snow and
Dyson hurled it into the master's room
this massive snowball had the intended
effects of awaking bodhidharma from his
meditation shangguan demanded to know
once again when he would teach him the
reply received when read snow will fall
from the sky
something inside shangguan snapped and
he knew immediately what to do
as a former warrior he always carried
with him sort he raised it high above
his head and swung it downwards in a
fast powerful cutting motion he had just
cut off his own left arm shangguan
grabbed his severed limb raised it above
his head and whirled it around the blood
still gushing from the left arm froze in
mid air and floated to the ground like
red snow seeing this act of
self-sacrifice Bodhidharma agreed to
teach shangguan their subsequent
conversation became another founding
Cohen of Zhen Sheng Wan beseeched the
master my mind has no peace yet I beg
you o master please put it to rest
but Adama said bring your mind here and
I will pacify it shangguan searched for
a while and then responded I have
searched my mind and I cannot take hold
of it then Bodhidharma declared now your
mind is pacified the next lesson from
body Dharma would require four more
years of shangguan life over that span
body Dharma asked him to live on top of
drum Mountain in front of the Shaolin
Temple at the beginning of each year the
master would dig up a well to provide
for all of Sheng wons needs each year
the water from the Masters well had a
different taste first bitter then spicy
next sour and finally sweet at this
point shangguan realized that the four
wells represented his life like the
wells his life would sometimes be better
sometimes sour sometimes spicy and
sometimes sweet each of these phases in
his life was equally beautiful and
necessary just as each of the four
seasons of the year is beautiful and
necessary in its own way murder Dharma
has imparted this lesson almost without
using any words the type of action
language that is fundamental to Qian or
Zen Buddhism after this final ordeal and
realization shangguan was given the name
quickiy by his master and he became the
Abbess of Shaolin after Buddha Dharma to
pay respect for the sacrifice week he
made disciples and monks of the Shaolin
Temple greet each other using only their
right hand
as I mentioned earlier most of berta
Damas life has been mystified by legend
but assuming what you heard is all fact
you might be wondering washing one was
barely surviving on water at the top of
drum Mountain always bought an armor up
to we can assume it was during this four
year period that he shared his teaching
with the Shaolin monks according to some
traditional accounts he may have taught
them how to fight the Chinese martial
arts collectively known in the West as
kung-fu may have been first introduced
to the country by an Indian wandering
monk so could this be true well as a
royal prince the young body dharma may
well have been already skilled in the
traditional indian martial arts moreover
he received additional training from his
buddhist master Prashant Hara and some
artwork at the Shaolin depict say
dark-skinned monk training lighter
skinned students in a variety of
hand-to-hand techniques however the
predominant point of view among current
Zen scholars is that the claim
Bodhidharma invented kung-fu is wildly
exaggerated for one thing the first
codified Chinese martial art GLD
predates the indian master by at least
30 centuries and while there is a record
of buddhadharma teaching some physical
exercises to the monks these are not
necessarily related to combat the
exercise is known as the eighteen hands
of lohan were intended to build up the
monk squee a vital energy to improve
their general health and nourish their
brains a necessary step to attain
awakening some scholars may argue that a
more realistic interpretation of bode
Adamas time at Shaolin is that he
perfected and taught his new branch of
Buddhism Chan or Zen so now I guess it's
time for me to explain what Zen Buddhism
is all about voted armor himself define
Zen as a special transmission outside
the scriptures no dependence on words
and letters direct pointing to the mind
of man seeing into one's nature and
attaining Buddhahood in other words Zen
requires a face-to-face transmission of
Buddhist precepts from teacher to
students outside the written tradition
and to do that you need a proper
certified Zen teacher
Eleni add Zen is not an intellectual
discipline that you can learn from books
or a video instead it's a practice of
studying the mind and seeing into one's
nature according to Buddha Dharma the
main tool of this is the
practice of meditation best known from
its Japanese name zazen beginners
approaching zazen are taught to work
with their breath to learn concentration
after a few months your ability to
concentrate may have ripened as you
progress you may understand that the
true goal of zazen is that there should
not be any goal nor expectation to a
particular meditation session
practitioners should learn to just sit
in meditation while learning a lot about
themselves along the way loaded arm is
lofty teaching in Shaolin and China
heard wanting a few disciples but also
some powerful enemies and we are told
that he was eventually poisoned by two
rivals allegedly the sage survived both
attempts eventually during the third
attempt buddhadharma accepted to take
the poison and died at the reported age
of a hundred and fifty but was death the
end three years after his death a
Chinese diplomat named song Yong was
returning to China from a trip to the
west when he met none other than bada
Dharma he was on his way back to India
walking barefoot and carrying one shoe
in his hands when the diplomat finally
got home and told this story
the Masters grave was opened inside it
was empty except for one shoe another
version of Madonna's last years on earth
tells of how the master left China for
Japan where he disguised as a beggar met
with Prince Shotoku Taisha
celebrated as the first great patron of
Buddhism in Japan while Bodi Dharma's
travels to Japan are quite strongly
disputed it is a fact that his teachings
did gain popularity there the master
became known as Durham and his
appearance and story inspired one of the
most popular symbols of Japanese
folklore the Daruma doll popular with
locals and tourists alike if you have
visited Japan you may well have taken
one of these home wondering what's the
reason behind the round shape and the
blank white eyes the shape of these
dolls reflects the nine years that
Doremus spent meditating in the cave
near Shaolin if you remember his
immobility was such that all of his
limbs had fallen off the wide opening
eyes of the doll remind us of how the
master to cut off his eyelids to remain
awake during zazen the dolls are
normally made without their pupils it is
up to the owners to draw them on once
their wishes are fulfilled over time the
doll took a life of its own
collecting attributes further and
further removed from the original
inspiration for example it was dressed
in red a color associated with measles
and smallpox and became a talisman to
protect children against these diseases
in a surprising twist artists of the Edo
era 1603 to 1868 even morphed these
dolls into phallic symbols the sexual
attributes were then shifted onto the
sage himself he became the object of
parody filled illustrations in which he
Liz prostitutes or courtesans around the
strange worldly tribute to the man who
once said to have a body is to suffer so
I hope you learned something new from
today's video and I hope that what you
learned is that you can't really learn
anything by reading a book or watching a
video I suppose
anyway we put out brand new videos
several times a week so please do
subscribe to get those and like this
video if you did like it and as always
see you next time